I've been talking about Hooters my
entire career you just needed the voice
I just needed the platform in the voice
I was even a Hooters waitress not for
real for comedy back in the day i wanted
the outfit and everything listen they
wear pantyhose so they are keeping it
classy put the pantyhose super classy
it's my special and still there's like
who and so I'm doing whatever I can to
keep Hooters legacy a lot we're gonna we
are getting my special is on Netflix
right now yeah I know you're busy you're
creating we can do one together oh my
gosh please can you call it hurts you do
you have any other plans like big plans
for 2020 oh man are you gonna get
married
I am it I I my fiance is here in the
audience
[Applause]
she's wait in the corner the accent yeah
bring this point for my
nobody puts Baby in the corner gonna get
married hopefully I mean that's the plan
right I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my YouTube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this